the West Hollywood City Council has
voted to remove president Trump's star
from the Hollywood Walk of Fame I headed
down to Hollywood Boulevard to gauge
people's reaction and I was actually
shocked by what I found will show you
them speaking of Hollywood some of the
biggest players in Hollywood are right
now very angry with me for pointing out
that the critically-acclaimed audience
dismissed movie sorry to bother you is a
lazy neo-marxist trash we will analyze
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez says more
stupid things
Candace Owen stops by to discuss her
white supremacy and finally the mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh so much to get to today we've got a
lot sorry we're a little late there is a
ton going on though we were just down at
Hollywood Boulevard I will show you that
clip it really really shocking before we
get to that let's make a little money
honey how about that does that sound
good and I'm gonna make I'm gonna save
you a lot of money I'm talking about
mint mobile look I have dealt with this
very personally you know you you sign up
for a cell phone plan then you get your
bill it's enormous
you call you can't get through you
bought the unlimited data whatever plan
and you pay an arm and a leg every month
it's awful dealing with those companies
is awful there is a solution I'm promise
you introducing mitt mint mobile the
game-changing company that's taken
everything that's wrong with big
Wireless and made it right this they are
not just disrupting the cell phones they
are revolutionising them mint bubble
makes it very easy to cut your wireless
bill down to 15 bucks a month that's it
no hidden fees no nothing 15 bucks a
month use your own phone with any minute
mobile plan you can keep your old number
along with all of your existing contacts
you can choose between the 2 5 and 10
gigabyte 4G LTE plan no more paying for
unlimited data that you're never ever
going to use if you're not 100%
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
with their 7 day money-back guarantee
outfox your old wireless bill start
saving with mint mobile I am telling you
right now you could cut your wireless
bill down by like an order-of-magnitude
do this right now you'd be crazy not to
get your new wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month plus 3 shipping on your
mint Mobile SIM card go to mint mobile
comm slash cough fa co v fe fe mint
mobile comm slash cough fac of e fe f e
cut your wireless bill down to 15 bucks
a month get free shipping on the mobile
sim card mint mobile comm slash cough fa
you might have heard about this the west
hollywood city council voted to get rid
of donald trump's star now of course
when they voted on that they had to then
urge the Chamber of Commerce and the LA
City Council on and on and on
to remove president Trump's star from
the world-famous Hollywood Walk of Fame
so I went down to Hollywood Boulevard to
see if the people who were walking
around on Hollywood Boulevard the locals
the residents people from Los Angeles
tourists to see what they think about
that local lefty government West
Hollywood's idea I was shocked by what I
found here it is
West Hollywood City Council has just
voted to remove President Donald Trump
star from the Hollywood Walk of Fame
I'm Michael Knowles I'm here to get
people's reactions on the removal of
Donald Trump star
should trump get to keep his store or
should they rip it up they see rip it up
I'm always I mean if it upsets people
just remove it I guess well he's a big
TV story had that show The Apprentice
what about the other stores that upset
people like the Bill Cosby store well
they didn't they weren't races against
people I guess are they didn't talk Bill
Cosby's are rapists against people
that's true you know right next to
Donald Trump star is Kevin Spacey star
what do you think we should do about say
Bill Cosby star I got a sleep what do
you think should the store be removed oh
it's that kind a hot official but I
think it's good so you think the store
should stay yes
this store doesn't bother you would you
say that you support Donald Trump or you
don't support him they just voted in the
West Hollywood City Council to get rid
of Donald Trump's star what do you think
about that or would you call yourself a
Trump supporter
that should trump get to keep it star it
doesn't feel like it's right just get
someone vandalize it would you guys call
yourselves Trump supporters I think you
know each other and they actually have
no power to get rid of that star it's
all up to the Hollywood here Chamber of
Commerce would you call yourself a trump
supporter yes there aren't that many of
us out here so it's really just a
symbolic thing that they've decided
because they don't like the president is
it you think it's virtue signaling
believe me it's good for business
whether you like them or not people want
to picture either thumbs down or thumbs
up so that's the first story Donald
Trump is good for business that's a
great idea I'm in thank you thank you so
that's what you have heard the local
lefty politicians here are so
disconnected from the people who
actually walk around a Leawood that they
all say one thing about the star and the
people on the street say exactly the
opposite an important lesson not to
believe the mainstream media and lefty
politicians a lesson that will always
serve you well
I'm Michael Knowles from Hollywood
Boulevard I like that guy who said he
was gonna build the wall around Trump
star I think we need to build a wall
around Donald Trump's store and we need
to make the West Hollywood City Council
pay for it and that wall is gonna get 10
feet higher and higher and how you're
gonna need a ladder to climb up and look
down into it I was really actually quite
surprised we were gonna go out there and
do a video about how all these people
are hypocrites right that's what we
suspected we'd find in Hollywood you go
out there you say should they remove
Trump star they say yeah I want to take
a sledgehammer to it myself yeah I want
to hit it myself and then you say what
about Brett Ratner what about Cosby
Harvey Weinstein what about all these
other guys and they'd say oh yes right
that was what we assumed we would find
but no the reason we thought that is
because the media are always hysterical
so they'll they'll always say oh yes all
these people in Hollywood they
hate Trump they won't get rid of him no
that isn't the case I mean look
president Trump's approval rating is
quite hides around fifty percent
according to daily tracking polls it's
higher than Barack Obama's was at this
time in his presidency he's actually
quite popular he's not popular with the
media he's not popular with local lefty
politicians you know the mainstream
media run 92% negative coverage of Trump
but he's very popular he's uncommon ly
popular with people and that's we found
that to be true even in Los Angeles even
in Hollywood and this brings us to this
other issue this huge disconnect between
the ideologue and the media types and
Hollywood types and people you know
people who live wherever they could live
in Palookaville they could live in
Hollywood but they're people who don't
work in the media or who don't work in
politics or don't work in those sort of
rarefied social areas which are
considered very elite that difference
you see this in a movie that I saw last
night that I am getting dragged all
around the internet for I saw the movie
sorry to bother you this movie is
getting Universal critical acclaim it
had a 100% on Rotten Tomatoes that's now
dropped slightly to 94 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes I said okay I gotta go see it a
couple of the actors in it I liked so I
said okay well I'll go see this movie
last night it is the single worst movie
I have ever seen
that is no exaggeration I've seen a lot
of horrific movies this movie I let's
just play the trailer can we play the
trailer I just really need a job
this is telemarketing stick to the
script mr. Davison cash the screen here
sorry to but let me give you two you
want to make some money here
use your white OS my white boys never
talking about Will Smith wife thank this
young man
hey mr. Kramer this is Langston from
reel of you as always we'll be getting
that out to you right away you don't so
good with the voice
all right
you're going upstairs power caller they
even have their own elevator welcome
power caller I hope you did not
masturbate today we need you sharp and
ready to go my power color okay so
they're not selling me but we certainly
know there's no amount of money that
make me do that here's the starting
salary I'm gonna have to get me some new
suits
morley emaciated I can't ride with you
I'm doing something I'm really good at -
they make you a proposal I can see that
you want to say no but I wouldn't do
that before you see what I'm offering
[Music]
you are awesome
this movie is uniquely terrible I
actually recommend that people go see
the movie just to understand how
degraded our society has become our art
has becoming our politics has become
you've got to see this movie I'm not
telling people to stay away from
theatres you should see it I mean there
were people who eventually after an hour
forty five they walked out of this thing
it was so bad but I was determined to
stick it out and I'm glad I did the
director of that movie boots Riley
actually tweeted at me because I gave it
a bad review on Twitter and he said well
I'm glad to have a bad review from you
you know a bad review from you is great
great encouragement it's a great
endorsement I'll explain why that movie
is so terrible why the critics love it
white audiences hate it before I do that
let's make a lot more money huh we do
that we keep the lights on in this place
let's talk about ring security ring is
so good ring is the video doorbell you
know I've talked about them before it's
the one that all the cool guys have so
when you go to like your cool friend's
house they'll have that video doorbell
where you click it and it goes right to
their phone they can talk to you too way
you know whether they're inside the
house there on the couch or they're on a
beach in Boca or something like that
it's really good and well so the the
main obviously it's very convenient but
the main use of this thing is security
there used to be the neighborhood watch
that is passe that this is it can see
who's coming there someone's to steal
your packages try to break in it uploads
the video directly to the cloud so if
they steal your ring doorbell you can
still get the video check out this clip
so crazy looking guy walks up to a home
and the first thing you hear is him
kicking in the door then the homeowner
catches him because of his ring doorbell
hey sorry we're in the middle of dinner
can I help you yes how are you good how
are you good seen you in a while no I
don't know who you are
I'm Justin I met you
long time ago yeah no I'm sorry you're
in the wrong place Kevin god bless for
both God
hey god bless Justin watch out when the
cops see that video you you might be the
one that needs the prayers you can see
what's going on at your front door you
can really stop a crime it's incredibly
empowering there's the floodlight camera
the spotlight camera you build a ring of
security around your whole property it's
it's a must-have right now I mean I
understand 10 years ago this technology
didn't exist so there were all of these
other ways that try to try to be have
security now you need ring save up to
$150 on a ring of security kit at ring
comm / Noel's kendo wles that is ring
comm / NOLs I love mine my friends love
there is everyone I know who has it
loves it $150 off when you go to ring
comm / Knolls cana wles
you can stop crime before it starts in
your neighborhood I've been giving these
out to my friends it's a great gift as
well definitely go get it okay
why is this movie so bad the the movie
suffers for for many reasons
there's nothing redeeming in the movie
there's nothing so to set it up it is a
Marxist movie it's a I suppose I should
say a neo-marxist movie because there's
a racial component added to klap this
class struggle issue it's you know it's
set obviously in the modern day there
are modern problems that it's allegedly
dealing with but it is a neo-marxist
movie and don't take my word for it
boots Riley the director admits that
himself he calls himself a communist
he's been a communist since he was 15
years old boots Riley joins the
progressive Labour Party which is a
Marxist Leninist organization he joined
it at the age of 15 he is a full-fledged
communist he's open about what this
movie is about
so it's deeply perverse and it's deeply
ideological which just screws up art to
begin with but the reason that really
matters is that you know art is supposed
to reflect reality it's but we're
supposed to consume art a movie or a
painting or a novel or something and we
see something about ourselves a better
experience of a human nature or
experience of the world this movie is
based on a false ideology in ideology
that should have been relegated to the
dustbin of history that ideology is
communism and that all of the premises
just don't work especially doesn't work
these days what they're saying is that
economic Liberty in this is really
slavery I mean they draw a direct can
action to that economic Liberty means
that people don't have jobs but we look
around us now the economy is much freer
we have lower taxes less regulation and
the economy is booming
everybody has jobs there are more jobs
than people to fill them right now the
wages are increasing prosperity is
increasing we know this to be the case
of our own experience of reality
contradicts this movie but there's so
much more to it there's so you know the
the communist slogan is that religion is
the opiate of the masses it's the it's
the opium of the masses and there's a
part in this movie where a guy that's
broken-down working-class man he takes a
crucifix and pops out what seems to be a
Eucharist and eats it like it's his
medicine like it's like it's an opiate
like it's a drug and that's that's the
other aspect that's a filmmaking aspect
of it so ideologically it's so wrong
that it you can't relate to it nobody
can people will pretend to relate to it
because they want to feel like they're
you know part of the working struggle
man but nobody really can but it's so
clumsy everything is so clumsy so the
the just as a technical aspect of
filmmaking directing writing it's really
weak I mean it's really just abysmal the
the main character's name is Cassius
green Cassius green you get it do you do
you get it cash is green it's really
really subtle and by the way if you
didn't get it his nickname is cash so
just in case you didn't get it the I
don't this is a spoiler alert you it
doesn't matter because the movie is so
awful it you should go see it but you
know it doesn't matter but close your
ears for 10 seconds if you don't want to
hear this the big reveal at the end is
all the people that are working for the
capitalists are turned into horses
they're workhorses you get it do you get
it
it's really subtle it's it's so bad and
and you know look I hate quick acting is
a hard thing working in show business
and already think so I actually hate
criticizing artists but the acting is
fine I'll leave it there the acting is
fine there's no standout performances
it's actually a couple there are a
couple very small roles that you have a
moment of oh that was good broadly
speaking the acting is fine to not find
in the movie
the writing is horrific the
cinematography is clumsy it's not it's
almost clever at points but it's pretty
clumsy the movie just is bad it's just
really shallow and bad nevertheless the
reviewers love it
94% on Rotten Tomatoes from critics 62%
from audiences that tells you basically
all you need to know st. Louis Dispatch
says sorry to bother you is an
uncompromising and timely film of
unapologetic brilliance Chicago reader
says sorry to bother you Ponder's the
danger of trying to assimilate into the
white world but it's a multiracial
proletarian call to arms one of the
premises of the movie is you can't get
ahead unless you use the white voice so
these black people have to talk like
they're white people the idea being that
you you you
if you become upwardly mobile you're
selling out your race that's that's a
premise of the movie and then the other
is that freedom is slavery I mean it's
really quite Orwellian and you would
think that the experience of people
under socialism and communism would
banish those awful ideologies to to the
end of history you know we had G
seong-ho come in here the other day from
North Korea that North Korean defector
I wonder if boots reilly would ever look
him in the face and talk to him about
how great communism is his family
starved under a communist dictatorship
he was maimed he was brutalized he was
tortured for years and years under
communism I wonder if moots Riley this
know nothing from America who grew up in
relative relative to the rest of the
world
utter prosperity I wonder if that guy
would look them in the face and tell him
how great communism is it's so I mean
the thesis of the film basically is
predict productive work is bad upward
mobility is bad laziness is good and we
should be unproductive and make bad or
it actually the film actually lifts up
bad art which is funny because it's a
very bad or really awful I've got to get
to it we've got Kansas own stopping by
very quickly I do want to cover Ocasio
Cortez saying stupid things here she has
taken away Alexandria she is she is the
leader of no no she I mean speaker or
rather leader Pelosi hopefully you know
we'll see she's a she is the current
leader of the party and I think that the
party absolutely does have its
leadership in the house we have our
leadership in in the Senate as well okay
well so
Nancy Pelosi is not the head of the
Democrat Party the chairman of the
Democrat Party is Tom Perez and Nancy
Pelosi isn't the highest-ranking elected
Democrat right I mean the the that would
be Chuck Schumer the leader of the
Senate Senate is a is a more powerful
more prestigious body than the House of
Representatives she just doesn't even
know these basic things and she's been
running for a while now
doesn't take Allie Stuckey to do this to
her keep keep going Alexandria so we're
paying for this system we Americans have
the sticker shock of health care as it
is and we're also not talking about is
why aren't we incorporating the cost of
all the funeral expenses of those who
died because they can't afford access to
health care that is part of the cost of
our system where do you even begin with
that the reason that we're not doing
that
is if people dying is not simply a
function of our current health care
system everybody dies every people will
die I know you might be shocked to hear
this Alexandria but under socialist
health care people will die - actually
we've seen people be killed by their
governments under socialist health care
just this year we've seen those poor
little babies in the United Kingdom baby
Alfie baby Charlie guard they were
killed by their socialist health care
system but they'll they will die they'll
all die at most in this world
one person has escaped death at most
right there's one guy and and you're not
him and socialism won't create him it
unbelievable her ignorant and it's it's
a beautiful thing I can't believe she
keeps going on TV I don't know what and
to watch Chris Cuomo fredo Cuomo just
mmm mm-hmm it's really terrific we've
got to bring on our dear friend Candice
Owens Candice as you know got in trouble
for being a black white supremacist the
other day a bunch of a bunch of white
lefty girls basically accused her of
white supremacy so let's I talked to
Candice earlier today let's bring her on
Candice you know I try not to have any
white supremacists on my show I really
make a point of that but I made an
exception for you you know you've been
in the news a lot recently as a black
female white supremacist what do you
have to say for yourself
not much here it is difficult in this
country being a black white supremacist
it's even more difficult when you find
out from white people that you're a
white supremacist but it's a difficult
week for me and my family but I'm coming
out on top here so those girls because
you did find out from white people those
girls who surrounded you started doing
the blow horns start whistling in your
ear they were all white I looked at the
video it looks like all of them are
these white girls who were yelling at
you and calling you a white supremacist
because you a black woman wouldn't do
what they told you to do that is exactly
right it sounds absolutely loony but
that is what happened I mean they are
they are really white I mean these
people and it's funny because
Philadelphia it's a forty four percent
black city so it's actually unique like
it's it's uniquely black it's forty four
percent black and that's not including
other minorities so it's a majority
minority city Philadelphia and it was
just I think one of the strangest things
that's ever happened to me what was
crazy is the entire police force black
so there was only one police officer
that was white the other ten of them
were black and Hispanic and they started
shouting at the police officers you guys
are race traitors and I said to them
whose race are they be tricky we are one
hundred percent of the black people in
this situation are on my side and then
that's unbelievable
and yes I mean this is one of many
incidents with you this week you you've
sent out that tweet it was so
brilliantly done where you took Sarah
Jong the the Asian of New York Times
editorial board member that her tweets
about white people her tweets
denigrating white people and you
switched the race and you were you were
booted off of Twitter for that I was I
was booted up a Twitter because for
harassment and you're not allowed to
discriminate based off of race and
gender but she was included on Twitter
she was not she kept the tweets up since
2013 so she's had those boots up she
hasn't even taken them down and looted
the controversy but instantly as soon as
I said it about black about black people
and Jewish people
I was wiped off and look I agree that
the sentiments are racist and that was
the point you know but why what is the
platform
when you say that it's all right to
discriminate against white people but
it's not okay to discriminate against
black people so you're you're saying
that now that you you get suspended from
Twitter and then Twitter finally puts
you back on after a day or two is that
so then it's and it's all good then
everybody big tech is okay with you now
no actually so three hours after I
tweeted that I was reinstated I didn't
even I didn't apply to be reinstated but
there was so much noise Twitter went
crazy with us and then they're big
people must have been like oh it was a
big accident they sent me an apology but
I just logged on to my Facebook account
I just landed in Arizona and I'm kicked
off of Facebook too I'm in facebook jail
for 24 hours with a warning for the
exact same tweet hey what can we say big
tech really cares about black people not
so much if your skins white wow that's
so what that is incredible so it's the
same tweet what you just posted the text
or a screenshot or something just you
know just screenshot of the exact same
tweet so it wasn't I didn't even like
redo it for Facebook's platform I just
screenshot like black people should live
underground like goblins but the best
part of the tweet is that I specifically
say under the following tweet is from
Sara Jang New York Times editor I simply
replace the word white with black and
it's not okay it's not acceptable
because that's where we're at in this
society they condone hate against white
people and they say that they're doing
it I don't know maybe it's it they're
they're calling balls and strikes and
because of slavery I guess whichever
just allowed to just be blatantly racist
to white people in this society because
black people represent a minority we're
allowed to be blatantly racist white
people in this society and I'm strongly
against it it's ideologically
inconsistent the oppressed are not
allowed to become the oppressors it
doesn't work that way it is incredible
because that the the your tweets so
clearly showed that that there is this
racial a double standard and that by big
tech by the New York Times by all of
these huge privileged institutions of
bigotry against white people is
tolerated and they talk about white
privilege but it's hard to get more
privileged than the Editorial Board of
the New York Times why is that you know
that what the Left says to this by the
way is they say you can't be racist
against whites because whites are on top
even though you know they use the wage
gap all the time
that's right asian-americans are on top
that's the register it's a craziest myth
the wealthiest people in this country
are Japanese Americans and Indian
Americans so it's it's completely false
to even say but they do know they don't
like those facts you know the people
that are most likely to get approved for
a mortgage loan at the bank are Asian
American it's not white people okay so
it you know why because it's based on
Friday and they have better credit than
everybody else so these are the facts
they conveniently wipe away they don't
want to talk about asian-americans you
know because it completely blows up
their entire argument that black people
are being they're screaming against
based off of the color of their skin you
know most of these circumstances
especially we talk about bank loans we
have bad credit why should someone loan
you money and if you actually look at
the statistics I've been reading this
book currently dr. Thomas souls race
intellectuals and he just debunk all of
these myths over and over again and
gives you that the concrete facts
another prop they don't want to tell you
is that black people are more
discriminating against black banks
anywhere else you know so it's all about
like society likes us divided they like
people to have an excuse to get through
life and I exist just trying to disrupt
that narrative because it's not healthy
for people on either side that is
exactly right because it's funny when
you mention they say the wage gap and
they compare everything to white men and
you say you know when you look at median
income according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics white men are not at the top
of the top earners in wages they'll say
well why are you talking about the
Asians why are you bringing that up and
you say look I didn't bring it up man
I'm not the one who's talking about
these racial categories you are but and
so they bring them up but then they get
everything even then wrong they get it
all backwards the wildest thing to me
there were two amazing things about that
video
one is that it's all these white girls
shrieking F white supremacy which in
itself is demonstrating white supremacy
right day they are the white
supremacists but then the other aspect
is when they run out of there tired
slogans and they just started screaming
sounds it was like demon lying in hell
you know why curdling shrieks like that
was like this is what I would imagine
hell was like you know if you were just
down there Satan was in your soul you
would just start Street it was
it's like it wasn't even animalistic it
was something entirely of another world
that's right no and what was that well
that's what I wonder what does that tell
us something I mean you were there
you're the one who experienced it does
it tell us something about the left does
it tell us something about their
arguments why are they you know I was
waiting for them to say like watch have
you to do with us candor so is what what
does that what does that tell you about
where the left is right now you know to
me it's very clear that they're losing
so in the same week we saw the Rasmussen
poll that was released which said that
black support has doubled for Donald
Trump since this exact same time last
year that's really significant because
the left since he has slept in office
how many times do you think if we had to
count you and I had to count MSNBC and
on CNN how many times they have said the
word racist and racism we wouldn't be
able to can't count that high and yet
despite that despite them aggressively
pushing this narrative black people are
embracing Donald Trump and that goes to
show you that it's not working anymore
that's falling on deaf and deaf ears you
can't you can only say it but so many
times before at least for me which is
like okay everything can't be racist I
mean anything that happens to a black
person is called racist we saw this week
LeBron James scandal it's okay you can
think that a black person is dumb
you can think that a white person is
dumb that could not be based off of
their skin color be based on their IQ I
mean there's a strong evidence to
support the claim that Maxine Waters the
low IQ individual you know so you're
telling me he who are telling me no
that's absolutely right it I do think
they're clearly desperate they're seeing
their divisive coalition breaking apart
right before their eyes and that's where
the scream comes from they don't they
they've run out of slogans and lies and
they just this this scream but before I
let you go because I know I've got to
let you go
I I would be remiss if I didn't bring up
my favorite conspiracy theory on the
internet which is that that video of you
with all the white girls yelling at you
really secretly you staged all of that
you paid the cops you staged everything
because I think it's basically left-wing
truther ISM yeah what does it say about
crazy it was like explain to me because
actually the Washington Post called us
at CNN called us asking
to answer that claim and you know
Charlie was so angry he got so angry at
the question that he calls me up and he
says okay could you actually call them
because I'm going to lose my phone I
suppose so I called them and I'm like
you know what I was like I'm not even
gonna answer the question I want you to
actually tell me how we could have saved
it
I just how could we have done it I call
the police officers I call and I'm like
I know you hate us let's just work
together to get this done I mean it was
just nonsense and in the person on the
phone the Washington Post article it
cover the scenario I was like do you
understand how impossible it is that we
created this scenario included within
Tifa to come harass us and colluded with
the police officers and the restaurant
owner who gave a statement and said I
didn't know it was going on I they just
talking about the window throwing things
at them and the funniest part which
nobody's talking about is that the
restaurant owner says I thought they
were vegans out yeah they're very nice
to the chickens and the fish you know
that that's it I'm sure I'm yeah you
would have had to collude with everybody
you probably would have colluded with
the Russians to what I think what it is
is that the reality is stranger than the
fiction they try remember our pal Allie
Stuckey did that fake interview with
Ocasio Cortez that's satire and they
said you're making Ocasio Cortez look
stupid you said we don't need we don't
need to make okay Hill Creek does look
stupid we don't need to make these
lefties look racist and and crazy they
they do just fine by themselves it
really it was such a strong case those
images are so vivid of seeing these
white girls shriek and these white guys
shriek and it actually helps us more
than it hurts us so I'm just I'm so
happy with it because so many people are
on the Left wrote to me and said I don't
recognize my party anymore you know this
is where I draw a line in the sand so in
this side no Democrat politicians spoke
out against it by the way so we'll see
what comes with it but I think that
stuff like this the crazier they get the
more desperate they get it just helps
our cause absolutely right well it's
really great work I hope you get your
hearing back from all those blow horns
and whistles I'll let you go I know you
just landed in Arizona but as always
Candice very good to talk to you and
you're the you're the one exception I'll
have no white supremacists on my show
except for you
talk to you later Kenya all right I've
got a say goodbye to Facebook in YouTube
if we haven't been shut off yet after
yesterday's show if you are on daily
we're calm thank you very much you
helped keep the lights on and cough fa
and mic up if you're on Facebook and
YouTube go to daily where that come
right now why why you ask well you get
me you get the under flame and show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you to ask
questions in the mailbag that's coming
up right now you get to ask questions in
the conversation I'm the one next I
think that's next week and most
importantly of all you get this this is
very important because when white Lefty
girls are triggered and upset by that
black white supremacist Candice Owens
you're gonna die I lost the train
somewhere I don't I haven't quite
followed it you're gonna need the
leftist use tumblr otherwise you're
gonna drown go to daily wire calm we'll
be right back with the mailbag
all right let's do it we got a run
through these as always running late
from Larry
my name is dumb Damaris
ah for the A's alright new subscriber
here and I love your show your bit today
about the leftist tears from Ohio had me
in tears laughing I would like to get
your opinion on what makes the
Democratic Party's think that if they
throw a fit long enough or loud enough
that they'll get their way I look at
them in pity because every time I see
them throwing a fit makes me think of
little kids at the store throwing
themselves on the floor demanding their
way and then I see a bunch of parents
Republicans dragging their butts to the
car and giving them a whooping but then
they don't come back any different it's
a bit daunting for me to see I know
y'all see it more than me but what's
your take on it that's exactly why the
analogy is exactly right because the
Democrats today basically the whole
party and certainly the left wing of the
party which accounts for about
ninety-nine point seven percent of it
behave like children they behave like
little children and why is that
why do little children misbehave well
because they're they're morally ignorant
so they're not you know they do bad
things they're there they are tempted to
do bad things and they're not really at
an age of reason and to because they're
poorly educated they they're not really
educated so they don't know very much
the same holds true of Democrats these
days there are very credentialed
Democrats these days they usually have
degrees from good colleges or a lot of
different degrees but the the quality of
the education is so bad that the trouble
is not what they don't know but all of
the things that they know that just
ain't so like in history or political
philosophy or or broadly in public
policy you know over fifty percent of
Millennials identify as socialists all
of those Millennials virtually all of
them were born after the fall of the
Berlin Wall they don't remember the
horrors of communism they don't remember
these things and because they don't
realize that life existed before they
were born they fall right into all of
those for excuse me a few too many
stogies they fall right into all of
those traps i we you've really got to
like with a child be patient you know
educate them have a little tough love
you don't want to torture them you don't
want to be too harsh
step a little tough love and um I think
we're seeing this happen
right now there's a big growing up
that's going on right now president
Trump's approval ratings are quite high
people are seeing that Freedom Works I
think all around the country we're doing
pretty well so let's hopefully hopefully
we can keep that up from Joel thanks for
being and ask me anything guest at the
new right Network now onto my mailbag
question you mentioned in an earlier
mailbag that you would advocate for
strategic voting I reside in Georgia and
we have a huge governor's race in this
November I know Brian Kemp the
Republican candidate is most likely
going to win due to Georgia's Republican
majority against radical Stacy Adams but
I'm considering voting for the
Libertarian Party for them to gain
ballot access statewide our state
Republican Party seems to be very swampy
and does not seem to advocate for true
conservatism whatever that is they
declared the district where my
university resides a lost cause for the
Georgia GOP any advice on this conundrum
I always advocate the Buckley rule named
for William F Buckley Jr ii wrote to to
vote for the most right viable candidate
you should vote for the most right
viable candidate so in this case that
probably means voting for the Republican
I don't know that it's a good thing for
the Libertarian Party to get ballot
access I don't know that we should have
multiple parties three third parties
fourth parties I don't think that
necessarily helps I don't see evidence
that that helps our politics but for
instance if you're in a place where
you've got two Democrats and a
Republican the Republican is simply not
going to win you know you're surrounded
by blue nobody's going to vote for the
Republican all of the evidence shows
nobody's gonna win and you've got a
wacko socialist and you've got a Joe
Manchin Democrat a more more moderate
whatever that means these days then I
think it's perfectly right to
strategically vote for the better of the
two viable choices for the more right of
the two viable choices even if they're
awful but in a case where you just think
oh I don't know if that Republicans
strong enough I think there are better
ways to move the party to the right then
by trying to create a third party for
instance or something like that I'm not
sure that that works Bill Buckley
famously did it in New York he started
the conservative party because the GOP
in New York was so far gone it was so
unbelievably liberal John Lindsay the
Republican mayor candidate eventually
became a Democrat
you know is that for going it's still
pretty bad so in that case maybe a third
party works in Georgia I'm not sure
George is that bad I'm not familiar
enough with Georgia politics on the
ground level so you'll have to make that
call
but I think broadly voting is about
affecting certain government bringing
about certain government bring about
certain public policy it's not really
about you it's not about you feeling
really good about yourself so if you if
the Republican isn't that bad and the
libertarian party who knows what they
will do
then I'd vote for the Republican from
Andy hi Michael
i religiously hate your guts obviously
obviously I mean just look at you what's
not to hate in all seriousness now you
said you were an atheist for 10 years
from 13 to 23 I myself have been an
atheist now for seven or eight years I'm
a conservative agree with all
conservative views on politics however
when it comes to God I don't see any
evidence whatsoever that a God or
anything supernatural exists literally
can't find a scrap of evidence
whatsoever that anything beyond the
natural that we know exists what
evidence did you see that I didn't that
showed you something supernatural does
exist
or is it those 10 years you were being
agnostic and really didn't did believe
in a higher power all those years thanks
hate your show all hail ben shapiro we
try to answer all of those questions
there first of all I don't think there's
any such thing as an atheist because
when the plane starts shaking when the
bullets start flying even the most
ardent atheist starts praying and also
the atheists who always talk about how
they're atheists they I don't know I
don't I don't talk constantly about
things that I don't think exists I don't
talk about unicorns all the time you
know so I'm really skeptical I think
people are in a relationship with God
and they either hate God or the hey or
angry at God or whatever I would have
probably called myself an atheist but I
no longer think atheists really exist as
for evidence of the supernatural I think
what you mean is the metaphysical things
beyond the physical world you know this
is a physical object even though it has
metaphysical importance the leftist ears
tumblr the obviously things exist beyond
the physical world mathematics exists
you wouldn't you're not a math denier
probably you would say the moral order
exists you behave in a moral way there's
something outside of time and space that
has
that there has a moral order there are
there are there is a metaphysics to the
world there is that which is not
physical ideas exist ideas aren't
physical those are those are
metaphysical consciousness is hard to
explain as a matter of just physical
processes I don't I don't there's no
evidence of consciousness as a physical
process your own thoughts the spirit the
mind the soul ideas those are all
metaphysical things what convinced me
that God exists is that the arguments
for God are quite good and there isn't
really a good argument against God there
were many good arguments for God the one
that got me my reversion experience was
a lot like CS Lewis's and I've been told
that this is very uncommon but it was
certainly true of me and it was very
similar to Lewis in that certain
arguments really convinced both of us
the ontological argument for one is a
really elegant little argument that that
did in fact convince me but it was
intellectual at first it was all just
intellectual I was convinced by that
argument there is the argument from the
unmoved mover the the primary cause the
cosmological argument the argument from
Beauty the argument from consciousness
there were there are many many arguments
for God and they're all pretty
compelling but it was slow I mean it's a
gradual process doesn't happen overnight
didn't didn't quite happen like Saul on
the road to Damascus there was a general
coming to and what are the arguments
against God existing pain suffering I
guess those are some arguments against
God existing but but really I think
those are arguments for God a world with
freedom will imply a world of sin and
pain would we prefer a world without
freedom would we prefer a world that
isn't the best possible world I don't
think so so I would explore those
arguments first of all and then I would
ask yourself why all of the great
geniuses throughout all of human history
have believed in God and have been a
pretty similar conception of God you
might want to ask yourself that some
girl was talking to Antonin Scalia in
New York Magazine she said what do you
believe in the devil too and he said yes
I do believe in the devil many more
intelligent people than you and I have
believed in the devil that's important
advice too it requires a little bit of
humility ask yourself this you say I see
no evidence for God God doesn't exist
because I don't understand metaphysics I
mean you said things in that question
that are demonstrably untrue right
that there there are only physical
things in the world you're writing that
down shows that there are more than
physical things in the world but ask
yourself this how good are you at math
do you know algebra
do you know trigonometry do you know
calculus do you know advanced calculus
do you know analysis stochastic analysis
you know what do you don't of course you
don't would you know advanced physics do
you know no you don't you have a pretty
elementary grasp of all of those things
why on earth would you think that you
have a grasp of God who is infinite that
you could pin pin down God that you
should understand God what would make
you think that you can't do
multivariable calculus what would you
think that you can understand all of
metaphysics that which created and
sustains the world probably not a lot
there I would ask yourself those things
but you need to be humble to begin with
you need to be humbled and it's very
hard to be humble when you're an atheist
there's this pridefulness that is just
endemic to that affliction of the mind
and fear of the Lord is the beginning of
wisdom humility and so you'll have to go
after that first as CS Lewis said you
you can't look for comfort when you're
looking for God you have to look for the
truth if you look for truth you might
find comfort in the end but if you look
for comfort you'll find neither comfort
or truth just soft soap and with wishful
thinking to begin and in the end despair
so look look for the truth and I think
you'll conclude what all of the great
minds and spirits of history of
concluded as well do we have time for
one more
would you like one more maybe just one
more I promise from Justin hey Michael
my best friend is an alcoholic and his
parents threw him out of the house and
he is now living with his girlfriend and
her mother who were also alcoholics
yikes he has a bachelor's degree in half
a master's and is working at a pizza
place and has dropped out of school
his family has told me not to talk to
him about it and that they've done
everything they can to do do to try and
get the help he needs and that I
shouldn't talk to him about it because
it will make things worse any advice I
don't know the particulars of your
relationship I don't know the
particulars of this guy I just know what
you've told me a little tough love helps
you need tough love some people think
that being friends now is being pleasant
being amiable no way sometimes you got
to be really tough with your friends and
usually it's a sign of friendship to be
really tough now what's going to work as
gonna work if you're just screaming at
them I don't know maybe that would work
is it gonna work if you use him into a
conversation you have a kind of
intervention you I don't know but people
don't have a respect for tough love
these days they think it's being really
mean you know harshing people's mellows
things like that
but it's not it's not you you need tough
love and real friends real friends have
that real friends have a real honesty to
them shallow friendships which I see all
around especially in this town I see a
lot of shallow friendships that's when
you go to brunch every so often and you
just oh how's the food oh it's good the
eggs are good hehe you know dude oh yeah
but real friendship is you're diggin
into real things it's two people
standing next to each other looking at
the same thing dealing really honestly
with one another you got it you should
be honest with them but you but you know
that relationship I can't give you some
duck triangle Proclamation you gotta
know the relationship because that's the
substance of friendship okay is that it
sad okay before we go because that's all
we've got time for here I do have to
remind you you're gonna have this
weekend just remember we are shooting
the second season of another kingdom
right now which is going to be really
good so you may got to make sure that
you check out season one we're actually
still live right now okay you really